las playas de la provincia peruana de
callados se ocurrieron de petróleo la
erupción volcánica en el pacífico sur
que produjo un tsunami en la isla de
tonga y un inusual oleaje en las costas
de américa complicó el proceso de
descarga de crudo de un buque en perú y
ocasionó el derrame según informó la
refinería la pampilla
las autoridades ambientales peruanas
informaron que los siete galones de
petróleo que según la refinería fueron
vertidos al mar no coinciden con la
cantidad que han sacado del océano el
ministerio de ambiente ha desplegado una
brigada para que atienda a la fauna
afectada y evalúe los daños
se evaluó playas costa azul y valla
blanca y se procedió al cierre esperamos
que las investigaciones den con los
responsables y sean sancionados al
momento del derrame la refinería colocó
barreras de contención de hasta 500
metros de longitud pero la marea sigue
contaminada con la sustancia
habitantes de la zona y defensores del
medio ambiente piden que se lleve a la
justicia a los responsables al ministro
de ambiente que por favor lo haga
seguimiento y que los responsables
que tengan una canción porque esto
afecta a los pescadores a la población
que nos alimentamos de la pesca y a los
animales marinos y a nuestra fauna
marina el tsunami en la isla de tonga
también ocasión oleaje inusual en la
playa de la región lambayeque que cobró
la vida de dos personas el domingo la
primera ministra mirtha vásquez pidió a
la marina que dé explicaciones por la
alerta tardía de tsunami